you are going to be playing the first
Wookiee Jedi Master which is effing
awesome what was it like actually
getting that phone call
um and what let's start with that well
my agent asked me would you be willing
to play another Wookie and I said yeah
uh and when I learned that it was going
to be possibly going to be a Jedi Wookie
a Wookie Jedi uh I was so excited
um I've always loved uh the Jedi I
didn't know I was gonna get have a
chance of uh playing one and this
opportunity with Leslie headland's
genius Direction uh just uh I'm so
grateful and I am so grateful to being
part of this because uh this new era
where what we're delving into where the
uh
um it's uh my favorite part about it is
there's lots of Jedi around yeah and and
that's that's it that was that was my my
biggest pull into the prequel movies
when I was a kid but I knew there was
going to be Jedi around and uh and I
can't wait to uh uh see uh the finish uh
I can't wait to share with the world
when it's done what do you think what
has surprised you about the tone and the
writing of this series and how it
compares to the other Star Wars that has
come before it well they think the part
of is this is uh like a mystery thriller
type of thing so there are lots of uh uh
little uh things that differentiate the
tone of this film uh this series from
from uh earlier stuff and that's the
mystery uh exciting part of it for me
and uh that's going to be very uh
interesting when it unfolds to people
and uh they're I think they're gonna
enjoy it